Cloris do you have a favorite scene or
moment in the movie would you care for
brandy perhaps before her time that was
a great
no thank you the never say good night
good night he it was Jean who gave me my
performance every time because he could
have said no thank you and he said no
thing so it made me I didn't expect it
you know react differently from anybody
else who would have said it's true -
Jean did jump in very quickly you asked
the question no he was right yeah
no thank you milk no thank you
Ovaltine now this film obvi this is your
baby but do you have a moment that you
particularly cherish in this film more
than any other as I love uh it's weird I
love a moment that's so weird there's
nothing - very little to do with the
ongoing progress of the movie
it starts with Terry and she says doctor
you haven't touched your food
and then gene looks at her boils up in a
rage and smashes his hands in the
potatoes in it he just puts his hands in
there and it's very embarrassing we're
all sitting there and it's just nobody
says a word sitting there with we're all
embarrassed I mean everybody in the
scene is embarrassed and then Marty this
is the moment my marty Feldman jumps in
and says I'll never forget what my
father used
at times like this I'll never forget my
father used to say at times like it so
don't say the bath and so on
No so he yeah but he's supposed to you
know tell us so he's supposed to wait
maybe pause it you know I'll never
forget what my father said at times like
this very patient I'm in a very and
finally Jesus what what that what do you
[ __ ] Marty says get out of the
bathroom give someone else another
favorite of mine was Terry's take
Terry's so sweet so feminine so blushing
she actually blushed you could see red
when when he looks at that gene looks at
the door and sees these incredible iron
rings and and bangs them and gene says
watt knockers and jerry says thank you
doctor
she was that was an incredible thing
what do you mean not oh he meant the
door knock regina guy my granddaughter
is here tonight and she doesn't know
what knockers means in either case oh I
want to tell her tell her
Alleluia where are you yeah hallelujah
that's your name that's her name
hallelujah where I am
dear there's stand-up I want to tell you
what knockers means G is stand against
my knockers well our knocker is like on
a door you knock on the door knock knock
knock and there also a term for breasts
knockers now you know you know BLC is a
very good time for you to explain that
right Russia's only long so I'm evening
that it don't mean it is not like I'm
using but educational that's what we
give you here at the academy